just of late there's been a subject or a
study that many people will have read
about many of you will have read about
by a physicist named Richard Muller who
is a very distinguished physicist who's
always taken a sort of a different
position on various scientific topics
and two or three years ago he began to
say critical things about the science
behind global warming and he decided
that in order to find out where the
earth was warming he would do a study
himself many members of the denier
community said well whatever Muller
comes up with we're going to trust that
so Muller did his study and he reported
out about three or four weeks ago well
lo and behold he said the earth is
warming and if you look at a chart of
his study compared to the other major
studies they lie right on top of each
other you can't tell one study from
another I think the deniers picked up on
Muller's work and unwisely in retrospect
agreed to accept whatever he said
because he had been very critical of
global warming and so I think there was
a leap of faith you might say or a leap
of hope on the denier community that
here's a very distinguished physicist
who's finally going to say that we're
right and the scientists are wrong I
think what we could learn from the case
study that Muller did is that he should
have trusted the other scientists and
the peer-reviewed prop peer review
process which had produced the data that
he was questioning in a recent interview
he said two years ago everyone should
have been a skeptic well two years ago
you had 98% of the climate scientists in
the world saying that they accepted
human-caused global warming you had the
data produced by Columbia University you
had data produced by NOAA data produced
by the University of East Anglia there
was no reason to question that data and
it was a little offensive at least I
feel it's rather it was rather offensive
and arrogant of Muller to simply say
well I don't believe this until I do it
myself if every scientist said
I'm not gonna believe what anybody else
did until I do it myself
scientists would be at least a century
behind where we are right now that is if
something is done by a reliable
laboratory which passes peer-review you
should at least put tentatively accepted
until somebody shows you some reason why
it's wrong so I think all of us who are
trying to educate you and other people
about global warming have mixed feelings
about Mahler I don't know that I like
his initial reasons but I think the end
result is an affirmation of what we've
all known or what we've been saying I've
been seeing more headlines now in
magazines and newspapers that say yes
the earth is warming there's no longer
any reason to doubt this and it is